a thousand years before geralt the
witchers were born but how do a band of
Elven outcasts and the destruction
wrought by the conjunction fit into that
story The Witcher blood origin reveals
it all
we last visited the world of The Witcher
in December 2021 when season 2 premiered
on Netflix as it turns out the franchise
is keeping the holiday tradition alive
as the prequel series blood origin will
hit the streaming service on December
25th 2022. what better way to celebrate
the holidays than watching
sword-wielding elves do battle
unfortunately if you're looking forward
to eight episodes of action like we got
with previous seasons of the actual
Witcher series we have some bad news for
you blood origin will only be four
episodes long however showrunner Declan
de Barra thinks that's the perfect
amount of time to tell this particular
story speaking with tadum dabara
explained this felt like a two-part
movie you never want to be watching a
movie going I love this movie and then
you start to look at your watch going oh
please end soon Deborah was very clear
that his story needed to feel right from
the point of view of the storytelling he
revealed that as they began editing the
footage the season organically fell into
a four-episode structure he continued I
wanted it to be a punch in the face so
that you can't take your eyes off of it
but if you like long running times it
looks like that's what you're going to
get as entertain payment weekly is
described the four episodes as meaty and
while we've yet to see a full-length
trailer for blood origin excited fans
got a little taste of what's to come at
the end of The Witcher season 2. after
the conclusion of the final episode the
credits are interrupted by a quick
teaser which takes us back 1200 years
and gives us a glimpse of our three
primary Heroes they Traverse the
forbidding Countryside with a storm
looming on the horizon and we witness
and prepare for battle a teaser for
blood origin promises a worthy entry in
The Witcher Saga
blood origin takes place before the
fabled conjunction of the Spheres when
the elves were at the peak of their
power of course Suave excel at science
and Magic their society is sharply
divided by class and plagued by war in
the prequel series we'll witness the
final days of this world before elven's
Society crumbled and the continents
became a land terrorized by all manner
of monsters my elders worked with humans
got robbed of all they had
and when they fought back they were
slaughtered
in this changing landscape the series
will focus on seven ragtag Heroes all
outcasts Who band together despite their
personal differences as the official log
line reads they must unite against an
Unstoppable power that took everything
from them their blood giving rise to a
prototype Witcher in a conflict that
brings about the conjunction of spheres
when the world of monsters man and elves
merged to become one what exactly is a
prototype Witcher speaking with to Doom
Declan dabara explained that while
witchers weren't really a thing before
humans showed up and established their
schools there were still systems in
place to bring about a very early
version of the supernatural Monster
Hunters dabara elaborated say geralt is
version 13.0 the upgrade ours is the 1.0
Rough and Ready the concept of a Witcher
it's the original model what was the
story there and how did that get lost
and who found that critical element
later
The Witcher series has never been one to
scrimp on big names Superman himself
Henry Cavill has played geralt of Rivia
for three seasons and when he decided to
step aside from the role Liam Hemsworth
of Hunger Games Fame was hired to fill
his Monster hunting boots in addition to
those two impressive Stars the original
series also features top tier Talent
like Anya chalotra Freya Allen and Joey
Beatty similarly blood origin boasts an
impressive cast perhaps the most
celebrated actor of the bunch is
Michelle yo best known for beloved
action flicks like everything everywhere
all at once and Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon and TV shows like Star Trek
Discovery here she plays an elf an
expert swords woman who's on a quest to
retrieve a stolen blade on her journey
she's joined by another elf raised to be
a warrior and taught by Yo's character
only to give up her predestined future
for the life of a musician the second
Warrior will be played by Sophia Brown
who's been a part of projects like Gary
[ __ ] and the capture a third hero is an
emotional and ax-wielding Warrior
seeking revenge for someone who died in
battle they'll be played by Lauren in
sephorian who's appeared in shows
similar in tone to blood Origins such as
Game of Thrones Vikings and into the
Badlands of course these three won't be
alone when they eventually band together
many driver of Goodwill Hunting Fame
plays a Storyteller with the ability to
shapeshift and cross both time and
various worlds Miron Mack of sex
education is a princess destined for a
future she doesn't want in her dreams of
following in the footsteps of her
historical hero a female Elven Warrior
a writer on The Witcher Declan dabaro
stumbled across an interesting problem
while working on the show's second
season as he explained to tadum the
mystery of the conjunction Spears led to
this whole show because I was working
The Witcher season 2 and we had a story
point we couldn't fix because we needed
to know what happened what was the world
before the conjunction Andre sapkovsky's
Witcher novels don't delve into the nuts
and bolts of the conjunction so dabara
decided to figure things out himself
owing so far as to map everything on a
whiteboard as it turns out Netflix was
very intrigued by what he developed
calling him up after season two wrapped
and asking if he wanted to create a
prequel series based on the concepts
he'd just come up with Deborah then sat
down in a cafe and began fleshing things
out on a napkin telling Entertainment
Weekly it was one of those rare David
Lynch in a cafe moments where the whole
thing comes out in one go and now he's
overseeing the entire show serving as
the writer and executive producer were
super intrigued to see what magic he'll
unleash a blood origin of ballads and
bloodied blades written by some Egypt
called Declan de para which deck
lindabara as showrunner Lauren Schmidt
his rich as an executive producer and
Andre sapkovsky is the show's creative
consultant we have to ask who's
directing The Witcher blood origin well
according to the show's official Twitter
account that job will be split between
Sarah or Gorman and Vicki jewson a
Gorman is no stranger to the world of
The Witcher as she previously directed
Two episodes from season two of the
flagship show she's also done work on
other series such as cursed the last
Kingdom and Jamestown as for juice and
she is new to the world of The Witcher
but her background and intense action
makes us think she'll be a perfect fit
for blood origin previously juice and
helmed the Rooney Mara Thriller close
and the Revenge flick born of War Alex
Garcia Lopez has stepped in to handle
reshoots Lopez is definitely comfortable
in the world of The Witcher as he
directed Two episodes from the flagship
Show's first season we can't wait to see
what these three helped create when the
prequel series hits Netflix on December
25th 2022. as showrunner deck lindebara
is in charge of shepherding The Witcher
blood origin where it needs to go he's
also the main writer of the series he
penned the first episode by himself and
co-wrote the fourth and final episode
however he won't be the only scribe
bringing this story to life as the Bara
has assembled quite the writer's room
alongside dabara the fourth episode is
reportedly co-written by Tasha Hugh a
relatively new screenwriter with big
projects in the works in addition to
blood origin she's working on an anime
Tomb Raider series and the upcoming Red
Sonja movie perhaps the show's most
impressive gets is Aaron Steward on
who's twice now teamed up with director
Panos cosmaros to create some
horrifically weird stuff most recently
they collaborated on the Cabinet of
Curiosities episodes the viewing and
most famously they co-wrote the script
for the wild Nicholas Cage Revenge
Thriller Mandy
The Witcher isn't exactly what you might
call a family-friendly show granted
Netflix is working on an animated series
meant for kids but other than that it's
pretty grown up fair both the actual
series and the animated movie nightmare
of the wolf boast a tvma rating but will
blood origin be any different will it go
the same dark routes as its predecessors
or will it take a Tamer lighter tone the
time of the sword in the ax is nigh
if you're a fan of how The Witcher
Universe has been presented so far then
you have no need to worry on the show's
Netflix page you can click on the
trailer and there you'll see the rating
displayed as tvma it also explains why
it's gained TV's equivalent of an r and
that's thanks to gore language nudity
smoking and violence looks like blood
origin is doing it all from exposed body
parts to severed body parts and even
gratuitous tobacco
while blood origin serves as a prequel
series to the first two seasons of The
Witcher you'll definitely want to check
out the flagship show first Declan
dabara has promised a new series will
feature plenty of Easter eggs for
dedicated fans they'll delve into
Mysteries like the cause of the
conjunction and the origins of the
monoliths and it will set the stage for
the terrifying World we've come to know
and don't forget to check out the
animated film nightmare of the wolf
blood origin will premiere on Netflix
and Netflix alone and we can't wait to
see it on December 25th 2022.